there's a woman right now she was from
the at t commercials i haven't seen a
lot of them but she's the the lady from
the the at t commercials milana vaintrub
she just wrote in this long essay about
how happy she is to have aborted her
child
she said over the past decade i've
hardly thought about my abortion except
for when i think of those who may not
have access to one she's saying i'm not
upset about my abortion i don't even
think about it i don't that's why i'm
writing long essays about it it's
because i totally don't think about it
and it had no effect and it was totally
a trivial event because now that i've
experienced a full-term pregnancy and
given birth i find myself thinking about
how imprisoning it would be to go
through this if i didn't choose it
a spoiler alert by the way 99 plus of
women who get abortions choose it
they choose to get pregnant because
they've had consensual sex all of us
with a uterus may soon be stripped of
the constitutional right to an abortion
it's awful here we are
i wouldn't have had my career
i wouldn't have had all of this if i
hadn't killed my child i couldn't have
sold cell phones on television
i couldn't have had the supreme joy of
selling
cellular telephone plans on tv
if i had not killed my child it's a it's
a horrific thing
i am i assume this is a completely fake
front and she actually is deeply
troubled by this which is why she keeps
talking about it
but think about what what madness a
culture has to descend into and a person
has to descend into to think that
selling
crappy cell phones on television
is
so much better
than
having a child and it justifies killing
a child that's the mad sort of culture
we're living in and we've all got to
we've all got to pretend that it's true
in this gaslighting culture i'm glad you
like that clip ring the bell subscribe
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you